hello they reject nation of Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey gene Jeter at the
patronage Eck topper worked here my man
scribble that sentence up lost little
girls short film from the guy gene I
ordered this calendar forever ago still
hasn't come in the mail where our ladies
gene I'm not lying
I have a receipt well flashing on screen
for you right now everyone thinks you're
a liar so this short film that he made
is says this is one of my favorite short
films it is about a woman who just
bought a new video camera and goes to
the conservatory garden and you know
Garden in New York attested out this is
where she meets a young girl I'm curious
what you guys would think about this one
haha well laugh at the end has got me
curious I'll tell ya I'm tell you right
now I'll tell you but only with my eyes
wow this is so beautiful
maybe I shouldn't have thrown away the
manual
how do I do
new camera problem
so really pretty
amazing
she had died Stan Divac
beautiful
that's a pumpkin
so I'm here in cerveteri Gardens and
this little girl wants me to help her
find her daddy
I don't know works here or you can call
the cops
I don't want to be in trouble okay let's
let's see what we can do no no come here
come sit by me I know what you going
anywhere until we find your dad okay now
don't worry I'm show you that he's
looking for you if he loves you very
much
Oh
there's a rear builder he's supposed to
take me to a really cool place where a
lot of people don't what the heck is he
dead
Camus there's something I
please where all the people guide Trump
is it daddy taking you there to teach
you some paper
[Music]
where do you think
does your number
you're not making any sense you're going
to be living with us and you will be my
new pet it's the devil
[Laughter]
Maji figured it's a joint like that lead
actors a lot I didn't do thought she was
great
mm-hmm and I really appreciated like the
very naturalistic approach to
found-footage I feel like a lot of found
footage has Dredd on the edges and this
just felt like I didn't I thought I was
joking about horror happening until she
started expounding upon her dad she said
like how the zoom works and everything
yeah I was like wondering where is this
going I could feel it's headed a
direction they actually did a really
good job with it because there was this
underlying tension throughout and it
felt like a found footage movie without
trying to tell us it's a found footage
movie you know yeah there's something in
the way that it's not too creepy and
it's also like she's documenting her day
in the park hey I just met this little
girl and also she's got to find her dad
so like in a weird way it almost seems
like something you might continue
documenting well the little girl didn't
oversell like some of the lines were a
little bit out there but for the most
part didn't oversell the attitude and
the tone of her performance it seemed
like in the right level yeah where it's
like this is a little bit surreal but
just subtle enough and that way the lead
actress could react in a way laughing
away
that's like she's just kind of being a
weird little girl yeah yeah kinds of
people at the party Park in New York
especially so that really worked is yeah
there were like motifs in the beginning
of it they're like this feels like a
found footage movie but you know I'm not
sure exactly then it escalated into
there and it gets to the point where now
people will interpret who she was the
daughter Satan I'm assuming yeah yeah
well that's the thing is if you've seen
a lot of the extended gene G diverse
like we have yeah I feel like the style
because I'm aware of your different uses
of style and whatnot at first I guess I
wouldn't have expected fountain footage
horror because you know you I feel like
you enjoy using a certain off the
verite style anyway a couple of the
things we've seen have a sort of
handheld homemade feel to them so just
within the bubble of jeans expressions
here they lured me in into thinking that
okay this is gonna be like a little
character piece of some kind well for
found-footage I thought it we felt
naturalistic I like what you brought up
earlier and it didn't have this polished
touch to it especially when she's
looking at the founder and you can hear
the wind just balancing it's amazing
wait a minute
camcorder effect yeah it's like when
you're trying to make a short film
you're like yeah sorry yeah and I
noticed that my thought process went
there of man picking up that win but
then I would but that fit was very real
for this idea of just a person grab like
getting a new camera and the weird lead
the zoom thing taught me something
because not that you know this is
applicable to every mode of storytelling
but it makes its own weird little tiny
character arc that is just amusing
enough to get attached to it's like
she's trying to figure out the zoom and
then the zoom pops in she's like oh
there's a zoom and like weirdly that in
is in is very endearing for this
character that we don't really get to
know about because you know her camera
that's why I thought her personality
really sold it in the way she responds
is very real and also a nice little
touch with like the dress the girl is
wearing like how can this girl get lost
mm-hmm she looks like she's well taken
care of to a certain degree
you know actually because that's the
thing is that like yeah when the ending
actually shows up you're like haha yeah
because I've made a joke which is good
idea yeah like oh really what they're
cool oh yeah yeah and then it makes you
appreciate how naturalistic everything
is up until that point and I thought you
did a decent job of like once I got
where yeah I thought it was either God
or a demon you know I was like is it
gonna be something like weirdly
uplifting and she's gonna help her find
Jesus and this woman is gonna also
literally find Jesus by doing so worried
our is it gonna be poor you you just
help the wrong person I wish you didn't
say haha at the end of your message to
me Jean gave away a little too much and
made me look out for something yeah
there's some curb hold clever cat all
right guys well Jean Jeter go check out
his YouTube channel eyes got trying to
laughs on there he's got trying to be
fascinated challenge on there there's a
whole wide variety of video short films
obviously guy just released a calendar
2020 he's a photographer as well so
every month is a new model new york
girls
girls calendar mine has been shipping in
the mail for two weeks wish they all
could be New York girl I'm not sure if
that helps with promoting your calendar
the fact that I've been saying the
shipping say you so look but then again
at the new place I live at there's been
quiet this is probably the third package
in the last four months where something
has just not been delivered and I know
it's just where we live no that's why
it's happening maybe Jean hand-delivered
it himself and then the building super
in the security guard guys like kicked a
mountain and and destroyed whatever he
was bringing with him how they had this
true mountain to the street see you guys
you